[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another Fandango indie movie guide
and as awards season starts to get into
full swing the movies just get better
and better this weekend you can see the
shape of water in limited theaters but
expanding from December 8 this is
Guillermo del Toro's latest magical
movie it's part monster movie part
fairytale part romantic melodrama and
completely something that only Guillermo
could create himself it stars Sally
Hawkins as a mute janitor working in a
government lab during the Cold War this
lab is hiding a giant fish man who was a
God in his own land
I can either save him
do this I'm gonna be synchronizing our
watches just like they do in the movies
great performances all around I mean
Sally Hawkins she says so much without
ever actually saying a word Octavia
Spencer is wonderful Richard Jenkins is
lovely and I just love the fact that the
main characters in this movie are a mute
woman a woman of color a gay man and a
monster so emotional it's an ode to
cinema and it's very much directed like
a musical it will sweep you off your
feet
do not miss the shape of water the last
he's coming for you
[Music]
and now for a great movie about the
worst movie of all time the disaster
artist directed by James Franco
everybody want to be star you had to be
the best and never give up when I get up
on stage in front of people
all I can think about is what if they
laugh at me you man you're fearless I
want to feel that too
I don't care I do it this tells the true
story behind the making of the room
which if you haven't seen and not to be
confused with pre-license room you must
go to see a midnight screening because
everyone gets involved and it's a really
fun time the movie is ridiculous so you
might think that this is making fun of
the guy who made it Tommy Wiseau who is
definitely a character played here by
James Franco played perfectly by James
Franco I should say but it's more than
that
yes you laugh at Tommy but you also feel
for him and it's strangely a very
inspiring story about a guy who just had
a big dream his dream was to move to
Hollywood and make his own movie with
his best friend and I think anyone who
has a big dream and goes after their
dreams will really take something extra
from the story it's also absolutely
hilarious and chock full of cameos if
you haven't seen the room I definitely
recommend you watch it before you see
this film because otherwise you might
not understand everything but do not
miss the disaster artist another one of
my favorites of this year
but why you can't Santa this is great
this is real acting I'm gonna ride
around with the dress maybe do it before
you shoot yourself in the head of blow
your brains out I disagree you're gonna
make this thing we are going to go
Punjab
[Music]
oh and make sure you stay right through
the credits of the disaster artist
because there is a post scene that you
don't want to miss now to what you can
watch at home this week and on Fandango
now we have mother this is Darren
Aronofsky's very polarizing film
starring Jennifer Lawrence and Javier
Bardem as a couple who deal with some
unexpected houseguests it's also an
allegory for the creation of the world
and the destruction of our planet and
the environment definitely not
everyone's cup of tea but I loved the
madness of mother I reveled in all the
think pieces and the extreme reactions
to this movie I think that's what cinema
should really do so if you haven't seen
mother or if you want to revisit again
and try to figure it out you can watch
it on Fandango now we've given you given
you kids it's just never enough
mother and also don't miss Jake
Gyllenhaal in stronger this is a very
inspirational true story of a Boston
bombing victim who lost both his legs
when he was cheering on his girlfriend
during the race his recovery is painful
and brave and messy it's not a
sentimental movie and Jake Gyllenhaal
does a great job make sure you have your
tissues on standby and watch stronger on
Fandango now I'm gonna walk with you
lien Sonya fantastic movies all around
definitely all in Awards conversations
right now so if you go out to the
theaters this weekend
don't miss the shape of water or the
disaster artist and at home you can see
mother or stronger I'm Alicia Malone you
can find me on Twitter at Alicia Malone
and I want to know in the comments below
or on Twitter what is your personal
favorite Guillermo del Toro film
I still love Pan's Labyrinth the most
but shape of water is really up there
I'll see you next week
[Music]
you